[Música]
hola a todos cómo están tienen que
responder bien hola a todos cómo están
bueno antes de empezar quiero saber
cuántos artistas hay en la sala así que
levanten la mano de 12
345 y ríen pero saben lo que me
sorprende es que no todos se han
levantado alemana
y cuando oyó que no todos
porque los humanos por naturaleza somos
artistas
y cuando dio por naturaleza es porque el
arte el origen del arte nace con el
origen de la humanidad
lo podemos ver estuvo siempre desde una
pintura rupestre
una danza ceremonial una pieza
contemporánea
el arte siempre fue un medio una forma y
una fuente de expresión
y es por eso que hoy los invito a hacer
artistas
y actualmente sigue siendo sigue
existiendo y está en todas partes y no
solamente los lugares donde la vivimos
donde la compartimos o se comparte sino
en cada una de nuestras actividades
diarias desde el plato que comemos la
foto que subimos a instagram desde
nuestro trabajo nuestra facultad hasta
el pequeño ración de dibujo que hacemos
en la esquina de una hoja
estamos haciendo arte y lo mejor de esto
es que los portadores y los generadores
somos nosotros los artistas
es por eso que quiero que nos demos
cuenta que el arte nos sensibiliza nos
transmite
y cuando nos transmite lo que nos hace
transmitir es cuando nos permite generar
un mundo mucho mejor
a lo largo de mi vida y espero que le
den muchos el arte me suelo encontrarme
conmigo misma
me subo a luchar por mi sueño a quererme
a conectarme
con mío y con lo que me rodeaba
y a medida que me di cuenta del impacto
que generaba es que empecé a valorar y
apostar por eso
es por eso que hoy los invito a
reconocerse como artistas
porque a medida que nos damos cuenta
vamos viendo el gran impacto que genera
así que quería en esta charla
compartirles cuatro de las cosas más
importantes que el arte me enseñó
a mí no están listos para escucharlo
están listas
una
y el arte nos ayuda a conocernos a
nosotros mismos
y esto la verdad que me encanta porque
cuando vemos o presenciamos arte nos
conectamos con el artista y con todos
los personajes que participan
y a medida que vamos transmitiendo y
conociendo más vamos reflexionando
sobre diferentes deseos emociones
sensaciones
que nos permiten
conocernos y muchas veces descubrir algo
nuevo
esto hace que juegue un papel totalmente
importante con nosotros porque
porque al estar rodeado constantemente
de tantas de tantas expresiones
artísticas es lo que nos permite poder
generar
y crear nuestros propios estereotipos y
aspectos estéticos
porque nosotros crecemos y aprendemos de
nuestro contexto cuando aprendemos y
crecemos de nuestro contexto es qué
quiere decir esas mujeres preguntadas es
que desde chicos estamos acostumbrados
y estamos acostumbrados y recibimos
diferentes tipos de conceptos y uno de
los conceptos es el concepto de belleza
y para poder romper estos conceptos
estos paradigmas es que necesitamos
seguir buscando seguir descubriendo
para poder cambiarlos
y lo bueno
es que más personas se están animando a
hacerlo cuando nosotros descubrimos y
buscamos más estamos ampliando nuestro
conocimiento cultural
ahora mi pregunta es si ustedes quieren
romper paradigmas ustedes se animan a
romper ese contexto
más fuerte
bueno él
se uno es que nos enseña sobre nuestro
pasado nuestro presente y nuestro futuro
y esto lo dije anteriormente el arte es
parte de nuestra historia universal
porque nos enseña a ver diferentes
realidades culturales diferentes
perspectivas y sobre todo
nos permite poder captar una realidad y
saber proyectarla
generando un pensamiento más creativo y
buscar nuevas soluciones
así que bueno es
y el bueno así que vamos con el tercero
es que nos hace libres es impresionante
como el arte nos permite transmitir un
mensaje poder conectar con otra persona
y sobre todo no hay límites
no hay conceptos correctos o incorrectos
porque cuando hacemos arte
está todo bien
y el cuarto
es que están los días
así que quiero que levanten la mano
quién tiene problemas
yo también digo que levante la mano
quien tiene miedos
quien tiene una crisis
soy 1990
quien no tiene preocupaciones bueno todo
mira
el arte y nunca pensaron que el arte nos
podría ayudar en esto
capas no nos quiten los problemas
pero quite los miedos
no nos quite
las preocupaciones o las crisis pero si
va a ser una herramienta sumamente
importante para poder afrontarlos
este es un poco de lo que me enseñó el
arte a mí y seguramente me va a enseñar
un montón más
el arte me cambié la vía y podría
cambiar ustedes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i